hello everybody my name is Mark Clark
welcome to zombies surrounded a
point-and-click style game where you're
trapped in a house alone and scared and
surrounded by zombies oddly enough so
you got to find your way out of some
horrible oh hello
i won oh hey I haven't seen graphics
like that since 2004 oh no a zombie oh
well that seemed to be the more rational
way of hitting an object trying to
swerve as opposed to most heroes and
stories hello probably not judging by
all the blood and the severe head trauma
and the internal bleeding in almost all
of my organs I'd say that I'm not
entirely okay also why do you live in an
abandoned Shack that's all boarded up
and prepared for the apocalypse
are you one of those Doomsday Preppers
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I didn't know
that host mood to be starting oh I
didn't know there's gonna be that type
of game I gotta have quick time events I
haven't played that since like it's
escort um ex mortem use wsad or arrow
keys to walk spacebar to interact oh
that's so cool oh that's cool I thought
it was gonna be like a more pointing
click oh that's cool
oh it stopped down oh that makes more
sense okay spacebar what was that
happened oh thank goodness you're okay
yes who are you what's going on I'm Anna
I'm a nurse from a veterinary hospital
in Georgetown I can't believe this at
all just an hour ago I was on my way
home and everything happened so fast
I'm not even sure where we are this old
house was empty though we couldn't stay
outside because of the zombies is that
the primary concern here markiplier
Mayans scream Lee boy how did you crash
are you sure you okay no no I'm fine I
really remember what happened okay well
oh hi I'm gonna stay down here and watch
the door I have a gun with me I haven't
been upstairs yet would you mind taking
a look around oh okay you haven't
explored the house that you've taken
shelter in certainly there are no
zombo's up there and me as the loyal and
brave screen Lee I hope I heard that
name wrong but I'm pretty sure it was
screen Lee screen Lee will find his way
about I need a screwdriver to open this
okay well I sure did jump to conclusions
there okay I'm just gonna be entered by
way upstairs
face first if you don't my hello who are
you
you okay buddy you seem to have some
stuff protruding from your abdomen and
why did I put my flashlight over there
see grab you lookin pillow dark stain
under the mattress probably due to the
blood I'm not sure I should trust miss
lady downstairs because something seems
to be pieced together a little oddly in
the scenario all right what do we got
books been chewed up by rats probably
fall apart if I pick it up well you
won't know that until you pick it up
can't reach that far what is it can't
fit under the bed neither well come on
I'm not that fat I can squeeze under
that gap it's okay
I'm the brave steam Li it's mean Li
extremely all right who gun can I have
that can has that what is this this is
the only thing I can find you write in
if anyone reads this you're not safe
here my son and I are leaving and going
north as soon as possible I heard
something on the radio earlier about a
safe zone your standards will steam we
should go to standards will I just I
don't know I am writing that I really
don't know what's going on except for
the fact that people are getting sick
and turning into ravenous monsters in
that case
I know exactly what's going on it's
zombies we knew something was wrong and
that we had to get out of the city but
we had to stuff at the gas station when
I stepped out of the car to get the fuel
that came out of nowhere and started
chasing us we wants to run for miles
before losing them we are going to stay
here for the night or at least until the
rain stops all of us supplies are lost
there have been too many close calls
today I've never been this afraid in my
life I was vomiting blood this morning
and I've been feeling dizzy
I haven't told Eric yet I hope to god I
don't get him sick but I can't just
leave him here alone Air Force closed
heard something about infection
quarantines seems like the world is
coming to an end
the radio stuff working there's no more
rain we need to sleep before we go
anywhere I'm taking the first watch I
haven't seen any of those things yet but
I have a bad feeling that something
horrible is about to happen it's just to
quit I saw a truck stop truck go by
there's no way I'm going outside with
two waved him no started bleeding again
okay I checked it's it's relatively okay
did you find anything we can use well
there was a hunting rifle but I couldn't
you exactly tout it around with me what
do you expect I'm not that strong I'm
very out of shape I can't even squeeze
under a bed how would I be able to do
anything about that uh oh I don't know
what I got but it's probably to help me
what did I get a broken wood why was
that by the bed you know what I'm not
gonna exactly question it but I'm gonna
use this broken wood on here burp bit
bit bit okay - by then ah maybe I can
yeah let me poke with my 13 stick I'm
gonna search up some there's some under
there what do we get now I can barely
see a goddamn thing where is it we go we
go batteries okay but I still need a
screwdriver how am I gonna be able to
get a screwdriver where's Astri driver
now I might be lost
Oh
Oh Oh aah that's weird why was there a
whole crack thing and how the key get in
there if that was I'm a little confused
about that but at least I have a key so
I can go upstairs I should be able to
open the drawer that requires a key ooh
kooky ha ha okay that's good so we're
gonna gold coins it may be valuable I
have no use for them now okay so for
later then and now I can turn on the
radio and be able to talk to someone I
guess let me just use my screwdriver
link and then lemme just put some
batteries in damages replace the thing
you boo
and now let me turn it on Oh No
Oh God we didn't heat our own advice oh
we're such oz bags oh oh
found this oh where are you going
there's a gun up here I'll shoot through
the window okay what can't you can't I
what you can shout it we've already had
enough noise ah boom I did that all my
skill Oh God caboose hey caboose key
however ste you got weird teeth you need
to fight your gingivitis I mostly come
on how about Oh
headshot oh I'm so good at games oh god
I'm a murderer
oh Jesus people Oh help us there's
zombies behind us and I'm just racking
up headshots left and right I'm such a
winner in saving this lady no oh no you
okay Oh Oh fine she's not fine yeah it
bit me when it came through the window
there was
but there was no window down there was
there I have to get out of here more of
them will come oh jeez that's quick oh
okay but uh oh god oh no oh why why in
her face oh god what happened now where
am I now what the hell happened what's
going on
Hannah no okay then damn or Hannah good
thing I was so emotionally attached to
her by all the dialog that we had
together it was great okay so there's
got to be some stuff here that I need
hello
I don't know what I just picked up an
axe blade oh I'll combine that with the
Doody daddy-o
ah okay that makes more sense okay so
yes they fit together perfectly who
knows why they were separated from Oh
God
that's not a good sign I'm gonna slice
the crap out of anyone that comes near
me I've got an axe
I'm ready to axe a bunch of questions
here huh yeah okay
I thought I was gonna hit it how about
that yeah that was quiet running I like
to did dictate oh god it's it's the me
it's the me of the military it's
literally the say oh god damn it
ah come on it was the same situation
it's just what I just said oh god it was
an entire world where there weren't
actually zombies it says everyone was so
paranoid about their maybe being zombies
they all went insane and I'm just
shooting a bunch of people that were
trying to save themselves then I get
shot cuz I'm a dick okay that was a good
game but here's my criticism about the
game it was a story-driven game right
like that's obvious this game is about
the story this game is about the
characters this game is up about the
people but this game does not introduce
the characters this game does not
introduce the characters dynamic with
each other
the
the woman who saved me I don't even
really remember her name very much
because it wasn't stated that much if it
was stated at all I honestly couldn't
tell you and it's not because I was
being silly about the game I was going
through the game and just doing random
tasks and yet I can't feel bad that my
character died if I wasn't attached to
my own character see there's a thing
about like stories sometimes don't get
you attached to other kids but I wasn't
even attached to my own character all I
know is for all I know I could have been
an escaped convict that just ran over a
person and dove into a ditch and then
stabbed a person in the face just as she
was trying to be healthy and helpful so
like this game was interesting it took a
lot of unique aspects to it with the top
down the point-and-click the QuickTime
events it was very interesting and I did
like it
however if you're going for a story
based game you have to definitely
definitely hammer hone those characters
because if you don't then there's less
attachment and less value for losing
said characters but that's just my
criticism again I've never made a game
I've never wrote and written a story
that's ever been officially published
that you guys know about so that's just
my opinion so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
think of it in the comments down below
and thanks again and as always I will
see you in the next video
okay radio the glut Oh
so the demons cake is this